next up is Kathleen Tate now Kathleen
she attended sage summit she came to my
session and then when i was leaving she
drove me to the airport so she's a
hardcore fan from Chicago she writes in
to say my fear is that I'm a social
worker attempting to get into the
fashion world I get motivation from
Evans channel now his book your one word
Steve advice I'm moving from a part time
entrepreneur to a full-time entrepreneur
yeah hey Kathleen I'm sorry that I
didn't give you a ride to the air for
but Evan Almighty he rocked in Chicago
he said the Windy City alive and you
know I think some context around that I
think we really have an opportunity or
in Social Work wow what a great what a
great job you do you know without you
the world would be just a lesser place
and people who do social work their
communities should be valued by
everybody and you know creates great
social cohesion we've talked before
about caring for the vulnerable so you
walk it every day now I think if you
want to get into things like fashion
designer fashion actually you've got a
great platform in terms of your current
job what are the advocate you do is
again you know you've got a big dream it
could be around fashion and we love that
um you get inspired by Evan which is
brilliant but you have got the platform
where I hate use that word but you could
kind of moonlight doing your current job
while you get an income from being a
social worker but use that and use the
time at weekends and evenings to start
creating your big idea and you probably
you know going to have a website
associate of that products and design
and and maybe even start talking to
potential customers and potential sort
of distributors and stuff right there
and even potential manufacture so you
could what would be a really cool idea
like this fear Kathy and you gotta
promise you're going to do this we're
going to do another these broadcast in a
year's time and you're going to come on
the channel and
say Evan I'm now running a designer
fashion business with a million-dollar
turnover and I did it because of that
broadcast gave me the inspiration and I
spent six months still being a social
worker but actually that gave me the
platform to build even if it's a few
hundred thousand dollars you know that
would be unbelievable and totally
amazing so I'd kind of say you know
drink with all these things kind of cut
the elephant down into little chunks you
got a great hopefully secure income
being a social worker user as a platform
do an amazing job as a social worker do
some moonlight in the evenings and
weekends to see how am I going to use
this platform to connect me with my
dreams my passion which is all about
fashion and then build that business go
after it build the business you know
fund it sensibly just to kind of kick it
off get get some product sales then
reinvest that in growth and then you'll
find you've got a business you love and
nurture the only tough decision you've
got is when you stop being the social
worker and give you notice really and I
would advocate that you kind of jump off
the diving board once you've got your
business and a bit of momentum and you
believe in it then then you should go
now the other thing right I've got this
great piece of advice from someone oh
wow when I went off to it was a startup
company at the time there's a company
called Oracle technology company
everybody knows them you know about the
time nobody knew there were no name
company and they were startup and I was
with a pretty safe company at the time
and I went to my boss and said a lot
they've got this our offer from Oracle
they sound like a pretty crazy American
company going to rule the world big
vision they got this guy Larry Ellison
running them and and he and I said I
really am torn because I've got a great
career here pretty saved earlier but I
think I would want to risk it
early-stage company and he said the good
thing is Stephen he said if you leave
and resign you know the doors always
open if you leave well and you never
burn your bridges so actually there
should be no fear about your decision
because your world light your trust
did you do a great job for us but most
of all you should go and try that and if
it worked out you're going to be a
Rainmaker somewhere else but if it
didn't work out the door's always you
know open here and and the only thing
that you might have to you know swallow
is your pride but you're a big guy
you're a grown-up that will be no
problem for you good advice so so
Kathleen I love 2017 to be the year
where you make it happen a new follow
your dreams and you're an incredible
brand in terms of designer fashion
that'd be amazing I like the one year
challenge to get to a million I love
that and what did you say but elephant
cutting it into chunks or was that
expression al they say this like they
say let's bring the moose in the room
yeah in Canada we say over in Europe
let's get the elephant on the table but
how do you eat an elephant you'd cut it
into very small chunks yeah break it
into two thousand trunks so when you put
a business plan together and you're
going to be the biggest design of
fashion brand on the planet Kathleen
you've got to break it into little
chunks what do I want to do for their 90
days hundred eighty days you know and
then you'll find momentum you'll find
you'll have a following you'll find
you'll have Raven fanatics as customers
and you'll develop partners and you
hopefully all your employees would be
brand ambassadors for you and then
you've got rolling thunder you got
momentum but you have to kind of start
small have a massive dream big dream and
and just a phrase I use yet cut the
elephant up in a thousand drunks and
then you can eat it and enjoy it eat the
elephant one chunk at a time all right i
said that i love like that for people
who are part time kind of move full time
i agree with stephen i would say you
need to make sure that you are spending
time every day on your business it's
easy to get caught up in your job and
responsibilities if you have kids and
you know life can get in the way and
then you never actually do the thing
that is also supposedly importantly
which is your business so make sure
you're spending time on every single day
even if it's half an hour like every day
something to help you
is grow and then try to figure out what
where your skills are best used what's
the highest value that Kathleen can
bring because people will throw all
sorts of ideas that you like Kathleen
you got to get on YouTube Kathleen you
got to be on Instagram Kathleen you
gotta talk to this manufacturer Kathleen
you know you gotta go to these
presentations whatever it is and you end
up doing everything in a mediocre way
instead of you know one thing really
really right so what's what's the
highest use of Kathleen's time that you
can apply in those 30 to 60 to 90 120
minutes a day to really make them count
you figure that out and then you're on
your way to going from part-time to
full-time and beyond hi Kathleen by the
way I'm Evan and I you know we're pretty
humble guys and we're really happy to do
product placements for really cool
designer clothes that you're gonna um
create over the next year or so so we
would be pretty cool to come on you know
heavens flap and you know I guess Evan
would love to wear a blue jay sure or
designer clothes created and brilliantly
inspired and nurtured by Kathleen so so
we'll do product placement for you and
will pump at the other they actually if
you get go in and you follow your dreams
i love i love what i love doing is
pumping out great ideas from I'm so on
social media so well we're going to be
able to help you can